quattro two and two
his month of july he was two and oh in
28 innings at 286 and his one start
uh coming against white sox he went six
innings three hits just one run so he's
ready to go he's been on a nice roll
akil badu hit the first pitch he saw
for a home run to start his major league
career off aaron sevalli in detroit
earlier this year
nice change up gotta hurry there's the
flip and he just did beat him to the bag
and the tigers are threatening and
ending number one with runners at first
and third one out no score and miguel
cabrera to the plate
if he hits the ball on the ground he's a
double play waiting to happen
gets the two for one the inning is over
and the indians are coming to back
the indians will be facing right-hander
matt manning who's making his ninth
uh career start at the major league
level
it's not the same picture as the last
time he faced the indians back on june
28th
and he should be running it in right
here like this one
nice play by candelario that came off
the bat
hot candelario got it on a short hop and
throws out straw easily
to start the night base is clear for
jose ramirez
we'll do it again this one right at
jonathan scope
a couple hard hit outs for cleveland but
matt manning retires the order
2-2 and a soft liner that's going to be
caught
zimmer with a nice sliding grab for out
number one
i mean he had that ball easily where he
just wanted the slide to make sure he
was going to keep it high
high victor reyes in right field batting
a buck 94
couple of homers nine rbis cuantros
ready as well
the wind and payoff swung on a missed
elevated the fastball got his first
strikeout
as reyes is retired along with the rest
of the tigers
no score third inning and willie castro
will lead it off for
detroit quantrill strikes out willy
castro his second
there's one down here in the third
here's derek hill the right-handed
hitting rookie center fielder
now the wind in the 01 and the swung on
banged ward third leaping rabbi clement
falling down throws to first
[Applause]
a high chopper that he leaked to get
falling down to the seat of his pants
with a one
hop throw to first and you won't see a
better play made
by an infielder in 2021 ernie clement
was the defensive play of the year
look who there he likes that now ernie
clement
after that sparkling defensive play
let's see what he can do with the bat
ernie turns it around down the left
field line into the corner it goes
hedges speeding into third he'll stop
there
it's a double for ernie clement and the
indians have runners at second and third
and nobody out top of the order and
miles strong
straw with a liner it's in the left
field to base it hedges will score
clement in the third safely throw goes
to nobody
but straw holds it first and mile straw
with his 36th run batted in on the year
and the indians have a one-nothing lead
indians at the corners for ahmed rosario
again not running up the middle and the
flip they get the one at second
they will not turn the double play the
indians get another run and lead it two
to nothing
runners at second and third with one out
for bobby bradley
here it comes it's swung and smashed to
first
by the diving scope down into the right
field corner
in the score rosario and ramirez
and a third stand-up double in the
ending
bobby bradley ropes one into the right
field corner
and it's four nothing indians harold
ramirez the hitter struck out his first
time up
here's the 0-1 a liner to center
on a bounce for hill bradley
trying to score the throw in time to get
him
trying to be aggressive right there and
a good play by derek hill
to cut that run off and that could be a
big play right there to charge up the
tigers
the 3-2 swing gonna miss up the ladder
with some good high heat
the fourth strikeout for cal quantrill
miguel cabrera coming to the plate
there you go low fastball after all
those high heaters
and 10 in a row retired by quantrill
and the table is set again for straw
ernie clement running
and a line drive right center field then
it is
a base hit i think no call now they call
[Music]
they may want to look at it because he
he may have trapped that ball
that's a basically a trap that's going
to be it should be but both runs should
score
the ground safe base hit
now runners first one third allow
hedges to score five nothing try
here's the one one swung on it there's a
high fly ball to center
settling under it drifting to right
center is hill tagging heading for home
and scoring
is clementine six nothing indians we're
in the fifth inning he's thrown 61
pitches painted the outside corner with
that fast ball and
could do nothing but watch it one ball
two strikes with two down here in the
fifth
up the ladder he went with the fastball
and struck him
out seven strikeouts for cal quantrill
two two swinging a miss and i'll tell
you what cal quantrill is on some kind
of roll that is
14 in a row and he has struck out
eight tigers batters he wants the
fastball in
nice got him beautiful fastball
ring them up number nine for cal cuatro
and six shutout innings of work for the
indians right-hander tonight
backhanded by rosario off balance throw
on the money
another sparkling defensive gem turned
in by the tribe tonight
nice backhanded play one two three and
he gets rid of it
look at that quantro is going to love
that here's jamer candelario
oh my goodness did you see that swing
that tells you all you need to know
about the tigers tonight
against cal cuatro strikeout number 10
and there are two gone in the inning
that's because he's been so good tonight
and it's a career high in strikeouts for
cal
congratulations he's been great broken
back cuantro will take it himself
what a way to probably finish seven
shutout innings a career-high 10
strikeouts for cal quandl
[Music]
oh my goodness harold almost took out
andre
and ahmed rosario says hey
hey powell he broke something because
fred mill went out and got a piece of
whatever it was
i thought i was safe back here just
broke he broke
the safety class oh my gosh you put a
hole in it look at that right behind the
end of the dugout there
all right send them the bill for base
runner and
this game becomes quite interesting
delario stands at home plate
here's another 3-2 this is ripped
through the hole on the right side
but due scores and the tigers keep them
loaded
and they're on the board tigers down to
their last strike
bucket the indians end their three-game
losing streak
they beat the tigers six to one as class
a closes it out
for his 15th save of the year
you